oh
le contrôle de police hier à dillon à
semer le trouble chez les conducteurs de
bras jack dans cette association un
camarade s'est vu saisir son véhicule et
signifier sa destruction prochaine à la
15 la répression a surpris et les
amateurs sont dans l'incompréhension et
la crainte de sortir on dit bon ouais
c'est moi jack l'a6 à samois jack café
nouioua jack a fait ça donc on nous met
tous dans le même sac faut différencier
les associations et celui qui fait ça
boit jack extérieur puisqu'il ya
plusieurs associations la jeunesse
bouhadja qui a envahi la place aux
promos yakoko industrie on nous sommes à
plusieurs yabré jack addict nous voilà
nous sommes des voisins sociation dans
le groupe tous les véhicules ne sont pas
forcément destiné à l'homologation pour
les vider mais on a l'habitude de se
rencontrer pour discuter et bien sûr
faire du bruit
aujourd'hui tout le monde est inquiet au
point de ne plus vraiment savoir où est
la limite
personne ne veut pétarader devant la
caméra et le message est clairement à la
modération
je ne veux pas tu que je remets en cause
tout le monde jusque on est tous passés
par là mais les gars arrêtez et puis ça
ça veut dire respecter un peu le
voisinage vous voulez faire peur vous
demande de faire petit hoquet une fois
mais n'allez pas au delà de faire péter
une minute trente deux minutes quand
parce qu'après c'est nous contre ces
noms qu'on réprime ont de concert alors
qu'ils risquent quoi pour les autorités
la réponse est simple la même
réglementation s'impose à tous
association ou non chacun est
responsable de son véhicule
assurance contrôle technique et si le
bruit fait partie de l'esprit bras jack
les autorités sont bien décidées à
encadrer certains excès quelle que soit
l'heure suite aux plaintes des
administrés et qui pose problème
notamment ses 7,3 cherche de pétarader
le plus fort possible j'ai envie
d'ailleurs et notamment la modification
des silencieux d'échappement pas
effectivement ces dispositifs qui vont à
un moment donné même on voit même des
intestins qui sortent de l'échappement à
partir du moment effectivement on va
dans cette direction là on prend le
risque que le véhicule soit
effectivement verbaliser mais que
derrière la procédure conduisent à la
confiscation du véhicule comme le permet
la loi et éventuellement sa destruction
impôts percier tolérée pour canal
mais sa modification elle est totalement
proscrite elle peut faire bondir le
nombre de décibels 203 homologué à 180
ou plus et quelques amoureux des bras
jack ont fini par se plier à ces règles
personnellement au début ça dérangeait
en fait parce qu'elle les boîtes bien
quand je vous fais du bruit et tout mais
au fur et à mesure en fait de la
progression de la boad jacques je me
suis rendu compte que cette simple gêné
parce que quand on regarde dans les
défilés à des petits enfants et ça peut
abîmer leurs tympans la ville de fort de
france se défend de tout vendetta contre
les bras jack les rassemblements de
jeunes ne sont d'ailleurs aucunement
interdit mais la police a toute latitude
pour verbaliser si la quiétude des
riverains et romy zaman
[Musique]